in essen gibt es seit einigen jahren
dieses neue gebäude den st anna kubus es
gilt als architektonisches highlight auf
dem gelände der zeche zollverein für 14
millionen euro gebaut muss das bauwerk
jedoch schon nach kurzer zeit für
mindestens 5,5 millionen euro saniert
werden nachhaltiges planen und bauen
sieht irgendwie anders aus finden die
essener nach zehn jahren schon
renovierungsarbeiten dran stehen dann
ist doch nicht normal
da ist doch nicht normal 2006 baut das
land das gebäude für eine private
hochschule aber sehr schnell gibt es
probleme mit dem extravaganten bauwerk
die dachterrasse kann nicht genutzt
werden hier besteht rutschgefahr der
sichtbeton bricht weg und das rostete an
allen ecken und enden
selbst die makellose fassade ist
mittlerweile mit rostflecken übersät in
die außenwände wurde eine spezielle
heizung installiert die mit warmem
grubenwasser betrieben wird doch die
förderung des gruben wassers wird hier
demnächst eingestellt dann müssen die
wände aufwendig gedämmt werden um das
alles zu reparieren muss das land noch
mal fünfeinhalb millionen euro in den
betonwürfel stecken
optisch finde ich sehr interessant ist
ein schönes gebäude das stimmt aber mit
so vielen fehler mich selbst die
schönheit nicht dann macht er nicht mehr
gut
im zuständigen düsseldorfer ministerium
versucht man nichts schön zu reden
sondern will retten was noch zu retten
ist schriftlich heißt es die sich seit
2017 im amt befindende landesregierung
betreibt im rahmen des sana a gebäudes
eine offene analyse mit den fehlern in
der vergangenheit und bemüht sich um
eine schadensbegrenzung und schäden gibt
es an dem essener betonklotz reichlich
auf dem dach wachsen inzwischen bäume
das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht dass da
nicht vorher im vorfeld genauer
nachgeschaut wird und die richtigen
fachleute daran sind ja sollte
eigentlich nicht sein
nach zehn jahren sollte sondern sollte
sich schon halten die aktuelle mieterin
ist die folkwang universität der künste
dort hofft man auf eine baldige
renovierung aber das kann noch dauern
bisher gibt es noch keine konkreten
pläne